la santé maintenant c'est la semaine du
coeur cette année les spécialistes
insistent sur la pratique du sport après
la cinquantaine elle est recommandée
sous certaines conditions et pour ceux
qui étaient déjà des pratiquants et bien
il faut surtout continuer françoise
valait ville de blaye et donc il ya ceux
qui regardent ce qui recommence et ceux
qui n'ont jamais arrêté comme hubert 65
ans assouplissement tous les jours à
7h30 matin même en hiver
depuis l'âge de 16 ans se sent bon le
coeur tout va bien oui je plus j'ai dit
moi je me fais de test
moi j'en sais et je me porte économie
pour la sécurité sociale
michel aussi fait faire des économies à
la sécu à 76 ans il s'entraîne trois
fois par semaine et se porte plutôt bien
j'aurais fait des tas de copains de mon
âge ils ont tous des douleurs la forme
et les bras les jambes avec la piscine
est ainsi faite on est bien quoi on n'a
mal nulle part vous avez une forme
incroyable
ayé de ont fait front en sang alors que
le tennis lui rejoue des parfums au
moins et les femmes ne sont pas en reste
plus de 70 ans et toujours sur le court
une activité sportive régulière serait
donc bien le secret de la forme mais
comment faire lorsque pendant des années
on a tout arrêté
comment faire surtout si l'on approche
les 50 ans l'unss critique pour le coeur
problème c'est qu'à 50 ans est souvent
le tabac il ya quelques erreurs
alimentaires et le cholestérol et donc
les artères du coeur en particulier
peuvent sans classe et c'est pour ça que
c'est important si on veut reprendre une
activité physique et sportive de faire
un bilan en état des lieux on pourrait
dire parce qu'une révision des 50000
pourvoir en fin de compte si le coeur
est en bon état et s'il est capable de
faire un effort et bonne nouvelle il est
toujours capable de faire un effort
commencer par la marche le vélo la
natation 30 minutes deux à trois fois
par semaine
progression et régularité sont les clés
d'une bonne santé